[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today hi Dina
how are you or Dina I'm sorry hi hi Dave
yeah it's Dina Merry Christmas to you
and your team and thank you so much for
having me on I've been listening for a
lot of years um I just want to tell you
that um I certainly have been trained by
my parents to um pay off my home and
that's what I plan to do um this coming
August I know about yeah I know uh thank
you we owe about 41,000 and what I I'm a
school teacher so what I plan to do is I
have a tax sheltered annuity that I've
had since
1995 and there's not a lot in there but
it's roughly around 28,000 so I was
going to use that to pay off my house
okay in August great okay and I've been
double thank you and I've been doubling
up on the payments to get it all cleared
out but here's my dilemma or I have
plans I have a home that's about 24
years old
and it is in need of like Renovations as
far as it needs probably um the siding
removed and put new siding up or fiber
cement or something like that is what I
really want to do and also possibly put
um a little sun room on the back of the
house and we have no debt my husband and
I we drive very old cars um we don't e
out of light so we kind of want to do
something you know to the to the house
like that but I'm kind of scared as far
far as I want to retire at
60 um but I don't know if I can swing
all this and without I don't know if I
have to get a HELOC or if I could use I
know you're not gonna pay off that house
and then borrow against it again right I
don't want to do that you're not going
to do that don't even say it out loud
yeah it's not even an option you've been
listening to this show you knew not to
say that here I know um but I know but
think about what you were really saying
I mean think about what's your household
income our household income is um 158
okay
$158,000 and you don't have a payment in
the world starting in August how much is
the sighting get a bid how much is the
sun room get a bid save and do one then
save and do the
other okay if you can save to pay off a
house you can save to do these
improvements it's just going to take a
little
time right well what I was going to do
is if I'm if I have the house paid off
um this August I'll be 59 and a half and
then like I would still work this school
year so I could sock all that money away
and at least do one of the improvements
and pay cash work two work two more
years who cares you're just a baby work
two more years yeah you don't have to
retire one year for the sun room one
year for the sighting you make 158,000
as long as you're working I didn't get
the quitting work part until just now
but yeah work a little bit more who
cares well she's like I care D I'm
pretty tired you have to choose okay you
got you got a choice do you want a
Florida room or do you want to work a
year you're right no I get okay I got
another question real quick can I I
don't have any we don't have any
heirs can I do a reverse mortgage what
are you saying well where is that woman
that called and said that she listened
to the
show where did you do with her you
didn't put her the closet lock her up
did you I think you're play you're
playing games with us are you playing
I'm exploring options don't explore
those I can I can still it's Christmas
we're supposed to be nice you're making
it hard you're turning us into Grinch
and Scrooge and everybody else okay okay
you know the answer all right so here's
the deal here's the deal get the prices
on the
stuff and then sit down and look at that
versus your income considering you have
no payments starting in August
AUST okay and really I mean it's
probably uh how many square feet is your
home it's roughly 1,800 okay all right
so $20,000 does a
sighting yeah I hope so yeah yeah yeah
and you can have you can have 20 you can
have $20,000 and do the sighting by this
time next year what what are you putting
towards your mortgage right now let's
let's look at this what are you putting
towards the mortgage you said you're
making double pay what is
that um I paid 3,360 a month okay that's
$36,000 a
year yeah so at 20,000 it leaves you
20,000 uh by this time next year at
Christmas you should be able to put
siding on the house in cash I should
yeah you're right and then by and then
by this time next summer you'll have a
Florida in
room six more months you got a Florida
room and and then then you're done just
just just plan it out the problem is you
you've got these things floating around
with no actual numbers attached to them
and they're floating around in your
brain in your emotions rather than in
your math brain use your math brain and
it'll calm you
down okay go get go get some actual bids
and timeline this out in your actual
budget like I just did and say okay
based on being done in August oh wait a
minute we could be done in July or June
oh wait well then oh my by February
we've got a sun oh okay you know and you
start when you actually get the actual
bids and get two or three bids so that
you're getting good
contractors and um and you know quit
entertaining these crazy butt ideas that
you know are crazy butt yeah oh my
reverse mortgage you've got to be
kidding me but there is something about
that that's worth speaking about you
know you you make it all the way through
baby step six you pay off your mortgage
there is still going to be things that
come up that you have to save and
possibly sacrifice in order to have it
doesn't take away do you know what I'm
saying like you don't get you never have
enough money to not watch your money
exactly like there's no such thing
there's going to be something you want
to do and you're going to have to pull
the P strings in Tighter and you're
going to have to decide okay what do I
want to what do I want to sacrifice or
trade in order to get that over time
that part never goes away it's it just
may not be to the extremes
that it once was right yeah being debt
free doesn't make it you know where you
have no boundaries you do anything you
want do it just makes it just frees up
the vast majority of your income when
you focus it with great intentionality
to do the next thing create your free
every dollar budget today the simplest
way to budget for your life